I feel like I'm Tom Cruise's love
interest standing next to you on camera
you know what I can't help my heightened
genetics Gregory what is going on there
citizens of the reject Nation Greg and
Coy here today we just got out of
watching The Flash movie I want to give
a special thank you right off the bat to
Christian harloff because Coy and I
individually we struggle to get into
early screenings we have sent so many
emails left and right text messages
phone calls and the only one who was
able to help us out was Christian
harloff we were able to get our names on
a list unfortunately neither coin or
myself could bring a plus one that's why
there's no John today you got us right
now and uh so if you guys can go ahead
and leave a like at any minute now we
might get kicked out of here I'm pretty
confident that I we saw someone make a
phone call for viewers on the edge we're
gonna have to make this really fast like
The Flash and speaking like the flash
quick promo for our new shirt right here
that verse of all the Batman here
shopzeroedition.com it's one of my new
faves one of the great ways to support
the channel and one of the great ways to
make yourself look good at yourself
anywho guys there's a lot that happened
in this film so real quick recap of what
happens in this movie based off of the
trailer so to make sure we're not
spoiling anything for you guys Barry
Allen AKA The Flash decides to take a
trip back in time to save his dear
Mother from her untimely demise but
little as you know his heroic act lands
him in an alternate reality where there
are no meta humans to be found a fear
not dear friends for Barry teams up with
his younger self the season Batman
played by Michael Keaton in the super
powered Supergirl to save the day
together they must stop the notorious
man of steel events from wreaking havoc
on this world and find a way to get
buried back to his own universe so much
is happening will they succeed and was
this movie good I think we should work
this review a little backwards today
sometimes I'd like to you know talk
about the story first and all that
themes whatever blah blah blah let's
talk about what we really want to talk
about how what'd you think of Michael
Keaton I mean everybody was waiting for
he's on the shirt you know what I'm
gonna own something Michael Keaton's not
the Batman I grew up with because my
parents are really young and I was young
so it's not like our household movie
like a lot of families I like the timber
Michael Keaton movies but I don't love
them with the same reverence and this
movie made me like the more I actually
like really got a lot of moments out of
the Michael Keaton Batman I didn't
expect to like land as well really
enjoyed it you could tell Michael Keaton
is having a lot of fun with this role he
is just relaxed fun Michael Keaton in
this movie and there's some Batman
action that you see teased in the
trailer where you're like wow he's doing
way more than you saw him do in any
of those Tim Burton movies and there are
some pretty cool fight scenes that he
gets here and it was a blast to see
Michael Keating while we're on the
subject matter Keaton I gotta say
there's also a lot of DC love letters in
here so if you're a Die Hard DC fan
there's a lot in here that I'm not going
to say because this is a non-spoiler but
know that there is a lot of like oh my
God I can't believe excitement Beyond
Keaton uh the Keaton is the one that's
in the trailers but there's so many like
oh my God that said I love Supergirl and
I have been very vocal about my
excitement for Supergirl woman of
Tomorrow the Tom King movie that is
being written by the guy that wrote the
comic and I honestly could see her in
that comic now and that was a really
cool moment for me as a fan of that run
that knows it's getting adapted I really
think she could crush it she has such a
strong presence in this movie she is
badass she is hot
ferocious being in this film and it did
make me go I hope moving forward in the
DC Universe that she gets to remain as
Supergirl because she is a powerful
presence she's so captivating so
immediately there's not a lot of like
need to go okay she's Supergirl okay no
no she's Supergirl you immediately are
endeared to her you're immediately
impressed by her just passion and it's
so apparent in every frame I'm really
that fingers crossed now we got to talk
about the person of the hour Ezra Miller
I feel like it's a obligatory thing to
say for every review I haven't heard any
reviews yet I'm sure everyone is saying
something along the lines of we know of
Ezra Miller's past credences and the
things Ezra Miller has been in the
spotlight for and we kind of just gotta
push that to the side for a little
bit by reviewing the film neither of us
condone the actions of one Esther Miller
this movie did something that I thought
was surprisingly clever as you see in
the trailer Barry Allen time travels to
the past changes some stuff so then
there's this younger Barry Allen who has
not yet become the Flash and they've had
different life experiences that younger
Barry Allen I feel like is sort of a
play on the criticisms that people have
held against part of the Annoying
humorous Parts even though I actually
really enjoyed Ezra Miller's work even
in the Justice League version I enjoyed
Ezra Miller's work there are these
criticisms that have been held about
Ezra Miller's character being kind of
annoying at times based off the kind of
humor and dialogue that that uh they're
given pair them up with our Barry Allen
who is a much more seasoned Flash and
has all these experiences a little bit
more serious this time around so you get
the juxtaposition the duplicitousness
The Duality as Coy loves to say there's
some Christians that I have about some
of the CGI in terms of using them and
some deep fake technology or whatever it
is they're doing some face swapping
technology but Ezra Miller absolutely
kills it and both of these roles fully
lived in makes the scenes believable due
to their work the parts I actually loved
the most were with them and everything
surrounding the heart of this movie
which was everything around Barry
Allen's personal journey I wanted to
start with the performances first
because so much of this movie I feel is
elevated by the performances what'd you
think of Ezra Miller I completely agree
with everything you said I do think this
movie does some of that Marvel magic
where as you grow into a universe you
can retroactively make things work and I
think Ezra Miller like you're saying
having that younger hymn that some
people critique the performance of with
our Barry Allen it shows the
juxtaposition The Duality of maturity
but it also shows what it would be like
to be around yourself and I love the
hero's journey of the self-fulfilling
prophecy of having to mature and usually
you don't get that in your face and I
love that this storytelling allows him
to realize the flaws in his thinking in
a way that is Visual and that is so
unique to a time travel story in
Flashpoint I think the emotionality of
Ezra Miller is second to none in this
use I remember a lot of people saying no
one else could play this part I remember
a lot of people saying they were in
every frame they are and they were right
about that because there are so many
amazing performances times two for two
hours it's just a Powerhouse take like
if you've seen uh Tom Hardy and legend
or any number of twin movies this is
that but in a superhero scale and at no
point did I stop and go all right
there's just one of them I kept thinking
that they were them it was fun with the
newer Barry Allen because at first he is
just annoying and when I say he I
understand Ezra Miller
reason he in terms of talking about
Barry Allen Barry Allen the younger
version the whole point is to make him
annoying right up right away and he was
to the point where I was like I don't
know if I'll enjoy this because he's too
annoying and then he becomes very
likable Ezra Miller managed to do that
thing where I was like I forgot about
all the things you did for a little
while because I was so transported by
your performance
oh right yeah Michael Shannon was kind
of whatever in this which is like how do
you waste Michael Shannon he was just
kind of whatever honestly and Ben
Affleck
I don't know what it was I thought it
was weird I even see it seemed strange
when you first see his action scene
that's teased in the trailer it's cool
but then there's parts of it where I
thought there's no way to the
physicality of the way he's being used
right now and it feels a little on the
freeway that you see you know what I
mean he's been tossed around I was like
this feels too cartoony that was one of
the main thoughts I had this feels like
a live action DC animated movie which to
its credit is a very big compliment and
at times makes some other things feel a
little bit strange especially when
you're used to those things being
weighted yeah that was every time
something was off it was because you're
used to it from another thing yeah so
like this has the magic of shazam's joy
and the gravitas of Zack Snyder's
imagery and the Nostalgia of like a
Justice League oh my God they're
Gathering but any time that you're going
from the Saturday morning cartoon but
more adults like the DC cartoons and
then you throw in a Frank Miller s Ben
Affleck you're like what is happening
yeah it's like this movie clearly
acknowledges the events of Zack Snyder's
Justice League but I kind of feel like
Ben afflecks was plucked out of the
Justice League one interesting because
the weight the flavor oh the kind of the
when it's just him in the suit talking
and it's like big and bright and cgi'd
out I'm like something looks really
weird about this I loved him when he was
Bruce like I love he had a good brace he
had a good Brew scene yeah I talked
about in our in our trailer reaction
that it felt like a splash page and a
smash of different artists all drawing
on the same page how exciting that was I
think it works in some doses but
sometimes it doesn't and I think those
are the ones we're talking about for the
movie itself I think that the movie is a
lot of fun there's some great action in
here I didn't love it as much as I had
hoped to love it maybe it was a little
over hyped I don't really know if that
factors in for my experience here
there's parts of this movie that I feel
are a little bit clunky for a movie
called The Flash I get that it's a
fast-paced film at the same time I did
feel like this movie could kind of slow
down a little bit this movie needs a
little bit of breathing room because it
kind of just keeps hopping from plot
Point like moving at such a rapid fire
pace I kind of got that thought in my
head that goes and then this happens and
then this happens and then this happens
a lot of the time I did feel like while
this movie maintained a genuine sense of
fun and reverancy for films of the past
not just in terms of the DC EU but the
films that came prior you could tell
there's a lot of love from behind the
camera even with the screenplay you can
tell there's so much love at the same
time there I do find that there are some
strange issues with this movie
particularly in the first act a little
bit in the third act even though the
third act delivers some of the best
emotional moments this film has to offer
and has some of the best tension and
Stakes this film has to offer I did feel
that this film as big of a Stakes as it
is weirdly felt like the emotionality of
the stakes was not really felt through a
lot of it and there was a lack of
tension in the finale I heard a lot of
people have said that it becomes like
this big CGI Fest there's a lot of CGI
but personally I wasn't distracted by oh
my God it's just becoming another CGI
battle monstrosity because it's so
consequential what ends up happening
there that it actually made up for a lot
of the experience that I was having I
was like I wish there was a little bit
more stakes in this movie that were
actually felt because there are so many
converging plot lines in here I didn't
really have time to have something to
worry about which I kind of felt like
was a little bit needed for me you know
what I mean you're dealing with one plot
with Barry Allen's and then now we got
Batman okay now we got Supergirl okay oh
yeah the General Zod thing that's right
you know there are villains being
villains but it made up for it by being
a genuine fun ride throughout with
proper fan service I thought they
executed from beginning to end there's
other things that we want to talk about
but Corey what's your like take on this
movie overall thoughts of the movie is
it's I think the strongest second act of
a DC movie ever I have not smiled that
hard I have not laughed that much I have
not felt that much joy and similarly
what you were saying about the First Act
it wasn't even necessarily purely pacing
for me it was that I had to adjust to a
sensibility the beginning of the film
because of the choices they have to pay
off later with the type of of clawing
annoying cloying Berry that's hard to
adjust to that sense of humor I kind of
worried it would be like a slapstick
humor that would carry on and that took
me a bit to adjust you and then I
realized the purpose and it all worked
out but I definitely am excited to see
it a second time because I found myself
being like oh I've heard this is the
second coming of Christ and it's not so
far and then I found myself really
distracted by overthinking my experience
that's not fun in a movie I do think it
is if not the best DC EU film it's in
the conversation for top three but I
definitely found myself being aware of
thinking of that which is a good sign uh
in the third act I was really invested
emotionally I was really invested in the
humor I was really invested in the
action but then there were a few moments
that the CGI made me go like oh I'm
watching a movie and that's never a good
feeling so all of the pieces were there
all the love was there as he was saying
the fan service is the most deserved I
think DC has done for all sorts of fans
whether you're a comic fan a TV fan a
movie fan there's so many types of
fandom in DC it delivers that but that
makes the the little details that it
pulls you away from a little extra spicy
like if the CGI is off you're so go in
that when it when it pulls you out
you're like oh I was it's like there's a
bigger Whiplash because of how in you
were I think one of the tricky things
going into this movie that I want other
people to experience that I wish I could
have I was expecting either a five or a
one and that's not fair to any movie I
wish I'd gone in going man I'm excited
to see this movie because when I was
able to be in that zone I was in the
zone I honestly want to lean into how
fun the movie is and I know that a lot
of people use that as a toss away yeah
and it's kind of exhausting because
these movies are made to be fun I didn't
think about the world for two hours that
is a gift but it does it in a way that
is not just rewarding for a casual
moviegoer it's rewarding for the deep
cut and when I say fun I mean I cheered
and laughed and clapped and guthawed and
the full Blockbuster experience that you
want from like a Jurassic Park or an
independence day or like the true summer
Blockbusters I kept hearing how good
this was but I wasn't sure about the
summer blockbuster feeling Landing
because of how many DC movies we've had
I didn't know if it would just feel
familiar and trite it doesn't it feels
original it feels bombastic it feels big
and fun which is a positive oh yeah
because the movie is clearly not just
committee made you know what I mean yeah
it really feels like they still had a
vision for this film you could still
feel the love again behind what Annie
mushietti was crafting he does seem to
seamlessly weave in and out of different
Aesthetics throughout this entire film
that was very impressive and especially
nailing down the emotional beats with
Barry Allen and and the story that he
has with his mom in this film that part
it almost brought me to tears uh I did
not personally cry at some stuff but I
came a little close maybe because it was
very predictable from the trailer of how
a lot of this was no Flashpoint if you
know Flashpoint if you know some Flash
stories it's pretty predictive there's
like a big twist that's supposed to
happen in this movie that's like the
second they introduce what the Twist on
me I'm like well it's pretty obvious
what the switch could be like
you might be really surprise for you but
that's what I mean by what this movie I
thought did contextually so well was
that even though the twist was obvious
the emotion behind it everything that
grounded that twist was rooted in how
does this affect Barry Allen as a person
and the consequences that Barry Allen
has to deal with the weight of choice
while this movie predictable sure it
still managed to ring a lot of great
drama out of these scenes that I was not
expecting to be so wrapped up in and to
have a great catharsis with on top of
that too there are some stuff that the
director himself has spoiled but there
is some big surprises in this movie that
the more you can avoid of online things
that have been leaking there's a lot of
things you can spoil do not watch TV
spots because I'm worried you will have
a very color by numbers experience
because this movie has surprises that
feel like they're delivering surprises
you're gonna want those there is an
action set piece that is so spectacular
that even though there were things that
were very clearly computer generated the
pacing the directing the style and the
commitment is all so incredible it's
probably in my top five actions set
pieces in the DC Universe so even when
the CGI is at its like whoa there's
still so much going on in a lot of these
scenes that I was like oh I'm still
wrapped up in the comic book spectacle
of those scenes I do think there's a lot
of amazing action scenes in this movie
as well like I've watched a lot of The
Flash television series so to me this
was like oh this is like the Cinematic
version of a lot of the sequences they
try to bring into life there like a lot
of the use of him going into the speed
forces excellent dude that opening run
the opening room was great and really
getting a sense of the distance between
Flash's City and where Gotham City is
there's a lot of just amazing sequences
there with some great humor implemented
throughout but yeah I think they're they
do some beautiful sequences all around
with our all the characters we listed
Supergirl Flash Batman I couldn't help
but compare some of the krytonian fights
to Man of Steel which I feel like is
still top tier level for me uh because I
was like ah you know Zack Snyder really
did that a little bit better with
the krytonian action but it was still
cool to see here there is some weird CGI
stuff that happens in this movie and I
found it most distracting and it's
really saved by Ezra Miller's
performance because as is great
throughout when you have both of them on
screen you can really tell when they're
like face planting or deep faking I
don't know what technology it is you
could tell which one is the actual one
they're filming within this take and who
the other one you know anything I only
noticed that twice I noticed it so much
it was so distracting I was very much
distracted by it and they have some
great use of the speed force in here and
there was this cartoony effect that I
was like
is this supposed to look cartoony
because they have a lot of these
surprises and but a lot of it looks
very cartoony that I struggled with yeah
there is an entire sequence that is
weighted in both spectacle and
emotionality I was able to experience
the spectacle with a little asterisk
because I was like oh I'm supposed to
feel spectacle could not experience
emotionality because I was like is that
a cake I could not experience a
spectacle of it because I was distracted
by this looks like a computer overall
koi would you rate it I'ma go and I'm
gonna get some spice eight points
four
maybe 8.5 but I gotta think about it
8.48.5 I'm like an eight I'm like an
eight point the more the more I look
back at it the more I'm like yeah I had
a lot of fun with that so I'd probably
say like an 8.3 I think I'm gonna land
on the 8.5 now that you've given your
number only because I remembered at one
point in the second act thinking that my
face hurts so bad that I needed to stop
it I couldn't and I love that feeling
it's a really really fun movie there's
there's no way to there's no way to get
around that it's a super super fun movie
anyway guys fortunately did not get
kicked out I have been seeing theater
attendees behind us constantly looking
at us and it keeps getting me worried so
we gotta exit out of here guys thank you
so much for being here subscribe leave a
like keep a look out for a spoiler talk
we'll catch you guys soon
foreign